رسميا الضوء الاخضر من اداره الغذاء
والدواء الامريكيه من اجل البدء في اجراء
اول تجربه اكلينيكيه على دماغ الانسان
هي شركه نيورالينك لصاحبها ايلون ماسك
وزفه الشركه الخبر في تغريده على حسابها
في تويتر معربه عن حماستها الاطلاق اول
تجربه لزراعه شريحه الكترونيه في دماغ
بشري الله يبشرك بالخير شركه نيورالينك
التي تاسست عام 2016 تسعه الى زرع تلك
الشريحه في ادمغه البشر لاهداف طبيه
كمعالجه بعض حالات العمى او الشلل فضلا عن
امراض عصبيه اخرى هناك ايضا استخدامات
اخرى لهذه الشريحه لكن علما ان تلك الشركه
كانت واجهت اواخر العام الماضي 2022
تحقيقا اتحاديا في مزاعم بانتهاكات محتمله
لحقوق الحيوان وصل شكاوى من موظفين بتسريع
تجارب على الحيوانات وهذا تسبب في نفوق
الكثير منها دون داعم بحسب ما افادت في
حينه
على كل حال عادل موضوع هذه شريحه ايلون
ماسك اثار جدل كبير كتير وكان في هناك
دراسات حتى انعملت بعدنا هو اعلن بانه راح
يبدا التجارب عليها دراسات بتتحدث عن مدى
يعني بتسال اسئله مدى اخلاقيه هاي الشريحه
لانها هي مش بس فقط قابله انها تستخدم لحل
مشاكل طبيه مثل الشلل او غيره ايضا ممكن
تستخدمها للسعاده بتصير مثل بتكبس بتضغط
على زر
لا بتحفز الدماغ على انتاج وافراز
الدوبامين هرمونات السعاده المختلفه طب ما
هذا بصير مثل المخدرات صح ممكن يكون
انا عندي قاعده انه الانسان هو عدو ما
يجهل دائما لكن قد يكون اذا اخذناها من
الجانب الطبي قد تكون مفيده جدا لماذا
نقضتها وجهه نظرك هي المفروض انه يكون في
قوانين بتحدد او بتضبط استخدامها لانه هذا
اشي كتير جديد وممكن يكون كتير خطير ممكن
يكون كتير نافع بنفس الوقت لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات